ici il a une histoire de fou qui se
passe dans le Var Olivier loue une
maison où il vit avec ses parents qui ne
sont pas autonomes un jour il dépose son
fils à l'école et quand il revient chez
lui il tombe né à né avec une pelleteuse
qui est en train de détruire la maison
c'est une histoire de fou vous allez
voir les images à bord le propriétaire
de la maison alors qu'Olivier avait
déposé plainte la justice ne lui a pas
donné raison c'est une histoire
incroyable olivier est avec nous ce soir
j'aimerais juste qu'on regarde pendant
qu'il rentre s merci Michel les images
de ce qui s'est passé regardez les
images de la la pteuse voilà donc la
maison regardez c'est un truc de fou
allez-y Olivier c'est un truc de fou
donc les explications du propriétaire
vous les allez avoir dans un instant
merci Olivier d'être avec nous donc
locataire de la Maison qui a été
détruite à la pteuse c'est que le
propriétaire a détruit sa propre
maison on va revenir sur ce jour à
luinon 8h30 bonjour Olivier d'ailleurs
bonjour vous déposez votre fils à
l'école et s quand vous rentrer chez
vous vous découvrez l'imaginable
l'imaginable et puis surtout mes parents
dhort mes parents 88 ans en train de
pleurer dehors sous la pelleteuse donc
il viennent d'échapper au gravas
d'accord c'est un peu une catastrophe il
faut comprendre que à ce moment-là la
personne qui est dans la pelleteuse
c'est mon soi-disant propriétaire on
apprendra par la suite que ce n'est
qu'un squatter qui m'a loué cette maison
les véritablees propriétaire aujourd'hui
on les connaît ils sont pas là du tout
et ils n'étaient pas au courant de de
l'histoire là c'est encore plus
catastrophique histoire de fond non mais
vous allez entendre cette histoire à 21h
si vous nous rejoignez c'est une
histoire de fou cette maison c'est 10
ans de procédure et c'est une famille
qui a volé qui a volé la maison c'est
une grande maison à des gens âgés en les
torturant en les privant de liberté ils
ont réussi à faire signer des papiers
pour une Esci qu'ils ont jamais
payéendesès les véritables propriétaires
aujourd'hui qui sont les héritiers de
Madame Fortier qui était cette dame qui
est décédée qui était une grande dame
une grande couturière de la télévision
française entre
parenthèses les héritiers aujourd'hui
ils sont âgés de se battent depuis 10
ans avec beaucoup de mal parce qu'on ne
les croit pas et cette famille ils ont
un peu abandonné la maison ils ont pillé
la maison il faut savoir qu'il y avait
un inventaire de 600 pages et
aujourd'hui il y a plus rien et pour
finir ben c'est les enfants donc le fils
de de de ce monsieur qui n'a absolument
rien à voir dans la si rien du tout qui
qui squattait cette maison et qui m'a
loué cette maison avec des faux
papiers il faut savoir que ce jour-là
incroyable il y a beaucoup de gens qui
auraient pu s'énerver je me suis énervé
vraiment mais j'ai pas voulu être
violent il est resté dans sa pelleteuse
alors racontez-nous parce qu'on on va
bien raconter
l'histoire vous allez vous habitez donc
une maison depuis combien de temps donc
là aujourd'hui ça va faire 8 mois 8 mois
vous êtes au locataire avec vos parents
dedans voilà parents qui ont quel âge 88
ans d'accord là vous amenez votre fils à
l'école et vous
revenez qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
pourquoi il va détruire la maison alors
c'est très simple on a fait un bail
classique un T5 enfin jusque là je
dirais que je suis un locataire lambda à
la seule petite différence c'est que la
maison est très
sale elle été squatté 10 ans et donc le
deal qu'on passe ensemble c'est 5 mois
sans loyer le temps que je nettoie donc
pendant ces 5 mois je fais 200 camions à
la déchetterie je nettoie les rats parce
que la maison elle est infectée hein
c'est c'est pas possible ils vivent dans
une crasse monumentale et au bout de 5
mois un jour il arrive alors j'ai eu une
faiblesse on on a tous des faiblesses je
lui ai autorisé deux chiens qu'il a
laissé dans cette propriété dans un
petit PAO qui est au milieu et dont les
chiens il les a laissé dépérir et je
l'ai laissé parce qu'ils savaiit pas où
les mettre se disant ces chiens-là et
jusqu'au jour où vraiment j'ai eu mal au
cœur parce qu'ils avaient à manger un
jour sur deux un jour sur trois et et un
jour je les ai libéré voilà je les ai
libéré et lui n'avait plus du coup le
droit de venir dans cette maison il
avait aucune raison et ce jour-là ça l'a
énervé forcément et là il m'a dit ben
non moi je veuxant que la maison est est
propre ben moi je vais récupérer un
garage et je vais récupérer cette partie
là qu'il a démoli et là je lui ai
expliqué que quand on est locataire
d'une maison avec un bail euh le
propriétaire n'a même pas le droit de
mettre un orail dans la maison h mais il
faut savoir une chose c'est un jeune
garçon il a pas la connaissance de la
loi même de la loi minimum le le le
civique on va dire donc il a fait un
petit peu n'importe quoi mais derrière
ça il y a quand même un ici de justice
qu' l'a conseillé je le dis bien qu' l'a
conseillé qui a fait une sommation pour
le laisser rentrer dans la maison et
pendant l'audition chez les gendarmes
Lucé justi de Brignol a eu le culot rel
devant les gendarmes d'insister de dire
que ce garçon avait le droit de venir
faire des travaux dans cette maison
travaux d'aération et c'est luicier pour
la petite histoire il est très au
courant du dossier parce que c'est lui
qui a entre les mains c'est grave hein
il a les documents que depuis le 24
octobre dernier il y a eu une procédure
par les héritiers et qui ne sont pas
propriétaires de cette maison ou donc il
est vraiment au courant il est complice
il est complice et voilà alors alors on
va on va VO parce que imaginez-vous vous
amenez votre enfant à l'école vous
revenez de l'école et là vous voyez
c'est là qu'on a envie de savoir vous
arrivez vous voyez quoi une pelleteuse
qui est en train de détruire la maison
voilà il est en train de détruire la
maison c'est fou vous arrivez on se
croit que c'est on se dit c'est
qu'est-ce qui se passe oui on a ça on a
ce côté où on j'ai pris surtout mes
parents mes parents ils étaient en train
de pleurer dehors ils faisaient moins 3
de donc pour parents comment ça se passe
ils sont tranquilles à la maison ils
entendent quoi bah ils ont ils ont au
départ ils ont cru que c'était moi qui
arrivait avec une pelleteuse en se
posant des questions ils sont âgés et
puis quand ils sont sortis qu'ils ont vu
la maison pour des gens âgés c'est comme
des enfants en fait même pour des gens
pas âgés hein ouais mais là ça était
vraiment un choc et il était sous la
pelteuse en disant mais il est fou il
est fou quoi il a pris la pelleteuse et
donc il a commencé à faire quoi détruire
la maison alors déjà il a explosé tout
le portail en bas littéralement et
ensuite il est monté jusqu'à la maison
il y a un grand chemin donc la pelteuse
avance tout doucement et il est arrivé à
cette maison il a détruit une partie de
la toiture une partie des murs et cetera
un peu n'importe o vos parents étaient
dedans mes parents étaient dedans donc
qu'est-ce qu'il font à ce momentl
pourquoi à ce momentl ils sortent parce
que ils sont inquiets l'état de la
maison c'est catastrophique donc ils
sortent dehors voilà et là ils sont en
train de de dire c'est moment où
j'arrive ils sont en train de dire
qu'est-ce qu'il fait ils pleurent ils
sont dans tous leurs états et là il
continue à détruire la maison il
continue il continue à détruire la
maison là vous arrivez parce qu'on on se
met tous à votre place on imagine la si
vous nous rejoignez à
21h5 Olivier va amener son fils à
l'école il revient il y a un mec qui
avec une pelleteuse en train de détruire
sa maison alors que c'est lui et donc là
il y a ses parents et là vous lui dites
quoi rien parce que d'abord il est dans
sa pelteuse je lui demande clairement de
sortir de la pelteuse oui et il sort pas
de la pellteuse d'accord il continue à
détruire il continue de détruire donc là
j'appelle la gendarmerie parce que j'ai
pas d'autres solution bien sûr la
gendarmerie dans les mêmes délais
appelle les pompiers Paris qu'il y a mes
parents qui sont là et c'est quand même
une situation catastrophique et il sent
au téléphone que ça va dégénérer et ça
va dégénérer pendant ce temps-là il fait
demi-tour avec la pelleteuse il
redescend le chemin et là il va en
direction de mes parents et de la partie
où mes parents habitent et là je me mets
devant la pelleteuse et je lui dis bah
non là tu là c'est clair tu n'avances
pas je et j'ai pas bougé et il m'a roulé
dessus non oh et euh ouais et là j'ai
pris un caillou et là je me suis
vraiment mis en colère donc j'ai les
gendarmes au téléphone les gendarmes au
téléphone ouais j'ai les pompiers qui
sont déjà en bas de la maison qui
attendent parce qu'ils peuvent pas
intervenir et moi je suis là avec un
caillou face à une pelleteuse voilà
avance vers vous la pelleteuse avance
vers vous ouais ouais il a avancé il m'
il m'a abîmé les les jambes les tibias
et cetera et euh quand j'ai le caillou
comme ça euh j'ai le moment de le
balancer ça c'est je pense que tout le
monde voilà mais je me retiens voilà je
me retiens je lui dis de sortir de la
pelleteuse là je lui demande bien de
sortir la pelleteuse et à un moment
donné pour éviter qu'il y ait un pépin
parce qu'il peut y avoir un pépin ça
peut déraper bah bien sûr j'ouvre la
porte de la pteuse et je tort une bordte
de sécurité qui est à l'intérieur ouais
pour l'empêcher de sortir pour le
bloquer dedans d'accord et là il crit
arrête arrête c'est une location arrête
arrête c'est une location mais
incroyable c'est c'est une blague arrête
blue non mais c'est une blague la B
c'est insecteur à la
bavure non mais on en rigole mais c'est
dramatique mais c'est ouais on en rigole
8 mois après c'est le moment c'est
moment donc il détruit il a détruit la
maison voilà il a détruit maison c'est
ça qu'on demande pourquoi tout
simplement parce que à quel moment il se
dit je vais aller chez lui le matin je
vais détruire sa maison al c'est très
simple moi j'ai eu la réponse aux
auditions de gendarmerie
euh il faut savoir que dans cette
histoire il a jamais fait de garde à vue
jamais de prise de stupéfiant rien les
gendarme quand ils vont le sortir de la
pelleteuse ils sont filmés par mes
parents ils sont en train de rigoler
parce que lui il a des amis à la
gendarmerie et c'est ses potes c'est
incroyable c'est c'est un truc mais
quand vous le vivez vous dites à un
moment donné vous savez que quand je
suis descendu en bas de la maison avec
les pompiers et ce caillou le une
gendarme m'a dit ah vous l'avez quand
même menacé avec un caillou il y a
violence hein ah ouais mais il leur dit
quoi alors alors alors moi je dis rien
je reste
calme alors c'est très simple ben il
avait envie de reprendre une partie de
la maison ouais et comme je luii dit que
bah non parce que je suis locataire je
suis dans mes droits et que il pourrait
faire ça au bout de 3 ans parce que
c'est un 369 mais pour l'instant basta
le portail resta fermé et il venait plus
mettre les pieds ici donc sous coup de
colère il a décidé de détruire la partie
qui devait reprendre sa propre ti c'est
un loyer non alors c'est ça le pire
alors c'est là maintenant c'est là
maintenant que ça va ça va reondir
écoutez bien parce queà 21h8 en fait ce
gars là et là c'est ce que vous n avez
dit parce que j'avais pas bien compris
maintenant on comprend mieux ça n'est
pas un vrai vrai propriétaire non non
c'est c'est une famille qui a acquis
cette maison mais lui il est c'est qui
alors ce gars ah c'est le fils d'un le
fils du du monsieur qui avait acquis
cette maison avec cette dame là voilà
d'accord mais c'est à lui la maison il a
Moné vous avz qu'il avait monté une SCI
vous le versez à qui le loyer à la SCI à
qui vous payez le loyer des 5 mois vous
avez fait le ménage il y a 3
ê pay j'ai payé à ce garçon pourquoi il
va détruire une maison si vous lui payz
un loyer alors là faud lui poser la
question et donc mais lui il dit qu'il
avait vous AAZ cédé qu'une partie du
logement et pas la totalité du logement
alors c'est là toute l'histoire qu'il a
cassé la partie à vous la réponse la
réponse qui m'a clarifié parce que moi
je suis resté quand même dans parce
qu'on a pas eu de avec ce garçon on n
pas eu de de de d'échange négatif avant
faut bien le savoir mais j'ai compris
quand il y a eu les auditions de
gendarmerie il a tout simplement dit non
mais moi je vais je lui avais pas loué
toute la maison alors justement regardez
ce qu'il a dit j'ai si vous nous
rejoignez à 21h9 histoire de fou Olivier
et locataire il pas ramener son fils à
l'école il revient il y a un mec avec
une pelleteuse qui casse sa maison avec
ses parents dedans et il y a eu un drame
en plus au niveau de votre père qui a eu
un un problème juste après euh il
s'exprimait propriétaire il dit je vaux
louer une partie de la maison un T5 de
seulement 100 m² sur un total de 400 m²
or il s'approprieré toute l'habitation
fait de la souslocation à ses parents et
exerce son métier sur place alors que je
ne lui ai pas donné l'autorisation c'est
quoi vous m exerciz quel métier
menuisier menuisier sur place ouii tout
à fait oui et vous le soulouez à vos
parents et je soulloue pas à mes parents
mes parents ils sont perdent d'autonomie
j'ai le la charge de mes parents et il
donne une explication sur son geste j'ai
prévenu mon huissier comme vous l'avez
dit que j'allais venir sur place pour
effectuer des travaux dans les 48 heures
qui suivaient la sommation donc il vous
a fait une sommation qui vous disait
quoi une sommation qui disait que je
devais lui donner accès à la propriété
alors ce sont des travaux d'aération il
m'a dit que j'étais dans mon B droit la
partie de la maison de la maison que
j'ai modifié c'est la mienne pas celle
du locataire est-ce que c'est vrai qu'
vous alloué que 100 m² sur les 400 alors
pour justifier de ça on a fait est- que
c'est vrai ça non non c'est pas vrai du
tout on a fait un constat d'hissier le
constat d'hissierit derre toute la
maison d'accord et il a justifier le
constatisser que c'était bien un T5 tout
tout tout compris il y avait
pas alors vous savez cette histoire de
T5 de T3 de T2 il a fallu que je
l'explique même à la gendarmerie parce
que les gendarmes ne comprenaient pas
histoire il comprenez pas l'histoire il
disaent oui mais vous avez loué vous
avez une grande maison euh mais oui mais
un T5 monsieur c'est pas c'est pas deux
chambres et un salon et c'est là qu'il y
a un blème sur le BA il y a pas les
mètres carrés sur le bail il on inscrit
pas les MTR Carr non on inscrit pas les
bail les MTR Carr n inscrit pas surtout
sur une maison où alors attendez on va
être clair sur le bal sur celui-là il
est marqué environ 100 m² environ 100 m²
parce qu'il y a une partie de la maison
qui n'a jamais été finie donc elle peut
pas être considérée comme habitable
marqué une maison garage en sous-sol 5
pièces principales 100 m car de surface
habitable voilà hab habitable il a
marqué ça sur le le BA dans le on est on
y est tout à fait mais on est entièement
d'accord làdessus moi je loue bien un T5
d'environ 100 m² pourquoi il vient en
détruire une partie parce que là il a
détruit deux chambres donc c'est
aujourd'hui c'est plus un T5 mais vous
aviez 400 m² ou 100 m² non j'ai 100 m² à
peu près d'accord quand 108 m² quand il
dit 400 m² alors il inclut il inclut les
sous-sols les garages et une partie de
la maison qui est de l'autre côté qui
n'a jamais été terminé parce que pour la
petite
histoire cette maison elle est en
procédure avec la mairie de Moissac
Bellevue donc le le le maire de Moissac
Bellevue a bien insisté là-dessus c'est
qu'il a jamais donné d'autorisation de
travaux puisque cette maison
est en nonconformité h d'accord voilà
donc c'est c'est un roule de de de de
statut heinors la justice vient de
déclarer qu'elle ne pouvait rien faire
par manque de preuve non voilà le
dossier laave aux victimes que j'ai reçu
ça a été drô
me c'est ça il y a des photos non mais
c'est quoi c'est quoi les c'est quoi par
manque de preuve ils disent quoi par là
ah benah en fait c'est là c'est là que
la justice elle reste euh silencieuse
comment on peut prendre sur le fait il y
a des aveux il y a des aveux hein ouais
alors moi je deviens un peu parano et je
me dis que les gendarmes n'ont pas
transmis les aveux au
parquet l'avocat mon avocat a transmis
un constat d'issier a c'est quand même
c'est parien qu'on s'ad ici c'est quand
même une preuve irréfutable et euh et
aujourd'hui on vous dit ben non mais il
y a pas de preuve non non ça c'est pas
une preuve voilà alors et c'est dur à
accepter alors c'est pas ma maison c'est
pas ma maison j'y habite dedans et
maintenant maintenant vous habitez où
j'habite dedans ah toujours voilà mais
comment vous avez fait vous avez la clim
en fait direct voilà non mais vous
habitez dedans là onment vous AZ fait
alors toute la partie qui a été cassée a
été sécurisée on a nettoyé les les
déblet et on a sécurisé la cette parti
là et on a réaménagé la maison pour
pouvoir y habiter dedans mais et donc et
donc vous payez toujours à ce
propriétaire alors aujourd'hui je ne
paye plus de loyer bah tout simplement
parce que j'ai plus de propriétaire
c'est une embéie pour vous ça c'est
incroyable alors pourquoi donc là ils
disent quoi la justice ah bah là la
justice elle vous dit très clairement
euh pour casser le bail qui est en cours
parce qu'il y a un bail quand même donc
mais là là vous êtes dans V bon droit de
pas payer de ah B toutalement donc là
donc là vous vous habitez tranquille à
l'œil tranquille à l'œil exactement ah
ouais ah c'est bien ouais en fait
l'histoire l'histoire se termine
bien tous les gens qui nous regardent
vont dire bah venez péter une partie de
la maison moi je dors tranquille non non
mais c'est vrai en fait le Dr le drame
il est pas là il est que la maison déjà
elle était dans un état insalubre et
aujourd'hui on fait tout le temps des
travaux dedans c'estàd que l'électricien
est V la con là vous payez zéro là donc
tout l'argent vous mettez dans les
travaux VO on met on met dans les
travaux en accord avec les propriétaires
actuels où ils sont très contents qu'onà
aujourd'hui tout ça c'est propre il y a
un jardin qui les propriétaires oui il y
a des propriétaires mais ils veulent pas
de loyer alors ils peuvent PAsie de dire
mais c'est mal alors c'est très
compliqué parce que ça ça rentre dans
les CADES dans le casadre de la justice
actuellement il y a une procédure il y a
une procédure pour acquérir cette maison
où il y a eu appel donc tant que l'appel
n'est pas donné là il y avait le trct
Opel voilà
euh je vois que ce soir on fait les
jeunes m exactement ou vous êtes content
alors là vous êes cont parce que non
parce que je pense que comme tout le
monde on est locataire on paye un loyer
pour mar vous payez pas de loyer ouais
mais on travaille beaucoup on travaille
beaucoup et puis il y a une espèce
d'insécurité moi je aujourd'hui on a été
obligé de de d'y mettre un chien de
mettre des caméras vidéo on pas caméras
vidéo çaarrêtera pas le tractopel hein
non mais par contre on sait qui vient
d'accord très bien benah là vous savez
aussi he aujourd'hui vu la réponse de la
justice aujourd'hui je pense que la
justice elle aura un autre sens par
rapport à moi le jour où ça arrivera à
nouveau bah très bien bah Olivier en
tout cas bon ça se finit plutôt bien oui
oui oui bien sûr merci en tout cas pour
votre histoire tout de suite ma sur T8
nouz pas la télé c'est que de la télé
merci mon